[Musique]
bonjour didier ni à nos jours vous êtes
un des grands patrons français
votre groupe pèse près de 8 milliards
d'euros vous avez changé nos habitudes
et nos usages avec free en cassant les
prix sur l'accès internet et sur le
téléphone mobile
vous êtes un patron atypique qui ne
rentrent pas du tout dans les codes et
on va avoir avec vous comment vous en
êtes arrivé là mais d'abord je voudrais
vous montrer un mot ce mot pirate c'est
un peu vous non je sais pas si c'est un
peu moi c'est envie de faire les choses
différemment que j'ai un parcours qui
est pas le plus linéaire possible mais
je crois parfois que ça peut être aussi
un exemple pour des pour des jeunes ou
pour des gamins qui eux mais non pas un
parcours linéaire c'est de leur dire
d'où vous veniez quoi vous ayez fait
avant on peut s'en sortir donc pirates
ça correspond à des bêtises que j'ai
fait jeune trentenaire un peu
transgression non on arrive en ou en
commençant ma vie professionnelle
indirectement par le piratage
informatique
alors on va y venir notre vie a changé
le jour de vos 15 ans puisque ce jour là
votre père vous offre votre premier
ordinateur
en quoi ça a modifié bouleversé le
réseau et demi déjà ça bouleverse ma vie
parce que j'ai je suis dans une famille
modeste à créteil et en fait on me donne
quelque chose sur lequel je vais avoir
le contrôle ou la possibilité de le
contrôler lui faire faire quelque chose
parce que j'ai des parents qui sont très
sympathiques
enfin c'est quand même à peu près les
encadrer comme tout enfant j'ai une
soeur plus jeune que moi et j'ai
l'impression que c'est elle qui est la
base de la maison et moi je suis le
maltraiter pointe jeudi su être celui
qui va pas être écoutés où on va pas
faire ce que j'ai envie que l'on fasse
et puis cet ordinateur là quand je fais
lui dire de faire quelque chose la vie
va le faire et bien les choses
immobile ces voix-là sujet un rapport
avec une machine qui va me payer un truc
de puissance en fait de pouvoir ou
d'existence je l'aï même encore plus
grand et donc on part de ça et puis donc
j'ai envie de le maîtriser de le
comprendre de comprendre ce qui est en
dessous comment il marche comment il
fonctionne et je vais apprendre un
métier qui va me servir après dans ma
carrière professionnelle c'est à dire
faire des logiciels pour faire marcher
ses ordinateurs alors très vite vous
arrêtez vos études
après votre bac et puis vous commencez
comme codeurs comme développeur et vous
et marie en gagnant de l'argent
notamment en piratant les décodeurs de
canal+ ce qui était évidemment illégal
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose de grisant
à pirater les décodeurs de canalplay il
y avait quelque chose de grisant de
réussir à contourner
quelque chose ne devait pas ou qui ne
semblait pas pouvoir être contournée ça
c'était drôle d'essayer de se dire
puisqu'on nous dit que c'est impossible
de le hacker dac est cette chose là
essayons de le faire et puis avec
d'autres copains ont fait ça pas besoin
d'être activé ou quand même on le voit
pas comme ça on voit juste un
contournement d'un système qui est là et
on a un gros passant par derrière
système nous a dit que c'était
impossible donc puisque c'était
impossible c'est légal mais puisque
c'est impossible mais ne pouvait pas le
faire donc je ne voyais même pas
l'illégalité de faire cela c'était plus
un défi donc avait quelque chose
d'excitant
il y avait quelque chose d'excitant à
réussir à faire ça ou à mettre ça en un
brave le sirha le faire
intellectuellement le défi était plus
intellectuel puis à côté de ça il y
avait des gens pour vous les achetez
gentiment on a un petit mot qui sonne un
marché noir
ouais des mineurs entre kraft d'accord
donc simplement à un moment donné vous
fait prendre par la police
oui hélas plutôt que de vous condamner
il vous propose un marché qu'est ce qui
vous propose exactement fait le la chose
qui me propose à ce moment là c'est de
dire super le piratage informatique
le piratage pardon ça c'est pas très
grave mais à côté de ça on voit que
quand même fait du piratage informatique
c'est là que vous arrive si c'est à vous
introduire avec votre groupe de copains
dans des sites informatiques qui sont
dans le calice à contiennent des données
qui peuvent être sensibles à avancer et
pourquoi pas pour plutôt que de vous
emmerder essayons de constituer un
groupe de jeunes aux personnes qui vont
nous aider à connaître mieux cet
écosystème et a avancé qui va nous aider
c'est qui le nous la direction la dst à
l'époque louis d'autres l'espionnage
français pouey les services ou qui à
l'époque n'ont rien sur ces systèmes de
piratage informatique
c'est disons rien ils commencent ils
débutent et puis donc on est quelques
jeunes dans cet environnement la rave et
donc ils viennent nous chercher puis de
les aider à avancer à constituer quelque
chose qui va qui va faire qui vont ce
professionnel qu'est ce que vous allez
faire pour les services secrets
bah on va être on va juste leur dire ou
ce groupe de copains qu'est ce qu'on
trouve qu est ce que l'on voit de les
tenir au courant
et qu'est ce que vous avez vu et
qu'est-ce qu'il avait trouvé
pour eux et donc la partie une fois on
se rattrape parfois on se rattrape et
compris par la presse et on se retrouve
enfin dans le cas présent je me retrouve
dans la presse pour avoir piraté les
téléphones portables on est en 86 avons
donc une grande prescription et pour
avoir piraté le la base de données des
portables mobiles français y compris
celui du président de la république du
président mitterrand ou de pendre haut
et ça vous le faites alors que vous êtes
dans les services secrets
je suis pas dans les services secrets je
suis un honorable correspondant je sais
pas comment on appelle ça on des
services secrets voilà à qui on dit
régulièrement ben voilà ce qui se passe
dans notre univers de piratage voilà
comment fonctionnent les services
secrets savent que vous allez les
pirates et le téléphone du gouvernement
et notamment du président mal car dit on
va leur dire voilà ce qu'on a piraté et
parfois je pense qu'ils ont un intérêt à
ce que ça sorte et d'autres facs ils
n'ont pas intérêt à ce que ça
parfois on a vu par exemple avec un
grand groupe automobile français on voit
qu'il y avait des gens qui arrivaient de
d'autres pays je le demande en dans mon
souvenir l'australie qui a excédé ces
choses là et qu'ils n'avaient pas la
même finalité que nous parce qu'ils
téléchargeaient énormément de données
quand nous on a les juges jeter un oeil
donc vous quand vous dites vous allez
jeter un oeil c'est à vous allez en gros
pirates et l'entreprise de grands
constructeurs automobiles français on va
se retrouver sur sa machine par hasard
presse à la ccl quel est le constructeur
le nom du constructeur des gros
constructeurs valeo renault de qualité
et donc vous infiltrer pour les services
secrets non pour nous en fait nous on
fait ça comme un comme un jeu par défi
et en fait on arrive par des fissures
ces machines là et on voit d'autres
entités qui sont intéressés par ces
choses là et est ce que est ce que vous
n'avez pas voulu continuer dans les
services secrets
c'est pas c'est pas mon job mon job je
deviens entrepreneur j'ai un
savoir-faire j'ai commencé à le vendre
et si vous voulez vers l'âge de 20 à 21
ans j'ai mes activités elles existent et
sur la base de ses activités qui existe
c'est plus mon truc moi j'exerce
paraître sont interdits à amuser
abbas est drôle c'est un défi encore une
fois ça continue vous utilisiez le mot
pirate tout à l'heure vous revenez là
dessus c'est allé voir l'envers du décor
et comment il fonctionne
vous passez ensuite au minitel rose
puisque vous allez faire partie de ceux
qui vont gagner beaucoup d'argent avec
le minitel rose vous allez développer
des sens
ten de 36 15 scott rencontres etc etc
qu'est ce qui vous attire dans le
business de l'érotique nous attirer dans
le sujet c'est quoi c'est quand j'ai
l'âge de 16 ans en fait tous les groupes
de presse se mettent à vouloir éditer
des services minitel
sauf qu'ils n'ont pas le savoir faire
technologique pour le faire et donc ce
qui se passe vous allez retrouver les
très belles images bravo vous êtes au
maximum maxime allais pas oublier c'est
ça le c'est ça le minitel rose c'est ça
le minitel rose mesdames vous avez
poussé le truc des niveaux vous voyez
pas les mets donc le show c'est que tous
ces groupes de presse voient un moyen de
générer d'obtenir des recettes
supplémentaires
sauf qu'ils n'ont pas le savoir faire
technologique pour créer ces choses là
et vous avez un groupe d'ados qui vont
les vrais dangers partis qui vont aller
travailler pour tous et ses sociétés
pour aller créer leur service militaire
sauf que quand j'ai l'âge de 18 ans
plutôt que d'aller travailler au travers
d'intermédiaire je veux dire je vais
faire ça pour mon compte et je commence
à faire ça pour mon compte
et qu'est ce qui fait que vous allez
gagner plus d'argent que les autres que
les autres concurrents vous avez une
méthode particulière mais la première
chose c'est que les autres ont une
une infrastructure extrêmement cher
comme nous comme on a vécu comme on a
grandi dans ce monde avec des moyens de
particuliers on arrive à faire tourner
nos services minitel sur des mets des
ordinateurs qui sont des ordinateurs
qu'on a aujourd'hui dans nos foyers
donc ça coûte très peu cher à produire
donc on a un prix production à
l'intérieur
donc on a une marge supérieure et on est
mieux disant dans les appels d'offres et
pour celui pour lequel vous travaillez
vous lui proposez des marges aussi plus
forte pour le forte et donc on gagne
contre tous ces gangs et donc vous êtes
beaucoup plus agressif vous allez on est
agressif commercialement on est plus
agressif en termes d' imagination des
plus jeunes
examinons va alors essayer de leur
présenter chaque semaine des nouveaux
produits quand vous écoutez les grandes
radios privées encore aujourd'hui toutes
les nuits vous avez des services de
voyance de rencontres ou autres qui
existent et on leur fournissait clé en
main ce type de service mais l'idée
c'est toujours d'avoir un service
qu'elle est plus rentable avec dedans
une idée originale de contenu c'est la
face contenté de parler juste de
rencontres ou de voyance mais c'est
d'essayer d'aller toucher des tonnes
d'autres services dont vous vous avez
une ligne éditoriale que vous essayez
développer je militerai la drogue est
mort et c'est de créer des thèmes qui
peuvent avoir un intérêt typiquement de
on peut aller chercher de l'espérance de
vie des jeux concours assez originaux
mais on va aller aussi vendre je sais
pas quoi de la literie on va on va
inventer des trucs hallucinants temps en
temps ça va marcher de temps en temps ça
ne va pas fonctionner mais on va essayer
d'inventer toujours des services et
comment vous êtes vous êtes perçu par
vos propres concurrents comme agressif
parce qu'on est jeune et con on a des
idéaux et vous casser les codes dans le
business les codes on casse les prix on
est extrêmement agressif mais on a vingt
ans vingt ans vous allez vous avez peu
de scrupules aller chercher les clients
des autres un peu de scrupules à être
assez agressif avec nos concurrents
quand il fonctionne on met tout en
oeuvre on est inconscient
on n'a pas de limites vous avez un
exemple de cela on a des milliers
d'exemples on va où j'étais condamné
pour ça donc on va le chercher sur les
sites concurrentes qui ont un peu de
trafic leurs abonnés pour essayer de
l'érable le pardon leurs utilisateurs
pour les ramener chez nous on dit très
agressif à ce moment là et ça c'est de
la concurrence déloyale en gros oui mais
bon c'est comme si chez la boulangerie
de mon voisin et que j'y vas aller à
côté c'est meilleur à ses proches à peu
ce qu'on dit d'accord alors en
du minitel vous allez investir dans des
sex shops j'ai en fait de cet argent là
donc je vais me retrouver à investir
dans des tonnes d'activité en se disant
simplement puisque moi j'ai réussi à
gagner de l'argent dans ces activités là
je vais aller investir cet argent dans
plein d'autres activités
oui ça va de la pizzeria au sex shop
ouais mais c'est assez large mais en
essayant de pousser ou d'aider des gens
en cherchant une rentabilité les recoins
de cette somme à pourquoi pas dès
aujourd'hui mais c'est un commerce légal
pourquoi parce que parce que j'ai un
associé qui est là dedans à ce moment là
et que c'est associé va mon nez là
dedans et c'est l'argent rapide en cash
c'est de l'argent rapide s'est
modérément fiscalisés nous on va dire ça
poliment et voilà vous ne déclarez pas
ce que j'appelle modérée de 5 à 10 est
ce que c'est à cette époque là donc dans
les années 90 que vous fin 80 début 90
que vous devenez millionnaire je viens
très riche entre guillemets très vite
parce que tout de suite gagnent beaucoup
d'argent moi j'ai des souvenirs de dès
l'âge de 19 ou 20 ans d'avoir des
salaires en centaines de milliers de
francs donc le très très vite cet argent
arrive j'essaie de chances de gagner
très vite beaucoup d'argent est votre
premier union je vois à 20 ans 21 ans
donc très seyant feront alors c'est une
autre époque mais on peut peut-être les
convertissent à vous a changé sur une
pas de manière consciente sûrement mais
à dire à ce moment là bas ce moment là
on est dans la baie dans l'instant et on
est les chips on reste humain mais c'est
quoi le choix collectif dans ces moments
là à ce moment là j'ai toujours pris un
énorme plaisir à les travailler vos
craintes étaient actionnées je ne je ne
vais pas travailler par contrainte
j'essaie dignement chance de le matin
d'aller muc de me lever d'aller
travailler parce que j'ai envie d'aller
faire cette activité est tous les jours
d'aller à inventer quelque chose de
nouveau et ce truc là est incroyablement
passionnants c'est une chance que je
souhaite vraiment à tout le monde après
est-ce que ça me change je sais pas moi
j'ai si vous me prenez quand j'ai même
25 ou 30 ans j'ai vécu
18 ans ou 20 ans à créteil c'est pas
parce que j'ai vécu dix ans dans des
quartiers un peu plus sympa de paris que
saddam changer immédiatement totalement
et l'expérience d'un minitel
qu'est ce qu'elle vous apprend m
apprendre d'avoir une curiosité sur tous
les secteurs sans exception c'est à dire
de se dire on peut gagner de l'argent on
peut être innovant on peut être
imaginatif dans tous les secteurs
possibles
et ça c'est tous les matins on arrive au
bureau et nancy qu'est-ce qu'on va
inventer aujourd'hui comme service qu'on
va pouvoir voir alors vous êtes à
l'origine de deux révolutions qui ont
touché des millions de français d'abord
en 2002 vous créez la boxe qui en plus
de recevoir la télévision nous permet
d'avoir internet et le téléphone en
illimité à prix cassés
d'où vient l'idée de la boxe c'est à
dire de cette boîte
en fait avec un copain en 93 ont créé le
premier fournisseur d'accès à l'internet
et la réalité c'est que moi je me fous
m'aviez dit à cette époque 25 ans ou 30
ans plus tard internet est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
je vous aurais pas cru pour moi c'était
un truc de chercheurs c'était très sympa
mais ça n'est pas être massif et on part
de ça et puis je vois cette chose
explosé avec des patrons de grandes
entreprises françaises qui viennent au
bureau se faire faire des démonstrations
d'internet des grands patrons de
télécoms par exemple télécoms mais aussi
au delà de ça deux banques jouent à des
jeux le patron de paribas à l'époque qui
vient au bureau sur faire une
démonstration de ce que fournisseur
d'accès à l'internet ce que c'est
internet et je vous dis moi j'ai ça chez
moi et j'ai l'impression qu'il ya pas ça
va pas est énorme et ces gens là ont une
vision différente et donc on se met si
l'intéressé mais au bout d'un moment on
s'aperçoit quelque chose qui est simple
c'est que si on veut avoir quelque chose
de en fait on a l'impression d'avoir de
l'électricité du gaz ou de l'eau mais
pas de machines chez nous pour
l'utiliser ce que voulait dire c'est
qu'il y avait des tuyaux qui permettait
aux mamelles de la du haut débit
on sait pas quoi en faire mais au bout
je l'amène chez vous et vous allez me
dire mais qu'est ce que je vais faire
avec ça aujourd'hui vous avez des
applications sur votre mobile vous avez
un mobile à l'époque on n'a pas le
mobile on n'a pas d'application sur le
mobile on sait pas quoi entrer dans ce
tuyau là on peut y passer à la télé fait
du téléphone de la télé de l'internet
exacte et donc on va dire super ce tuyau
lenval on va absolument nécessaire à
votre foyer
encore une fois sur le même modèle que
le gaz et l'eau ou l'électricité il faut
juste l'équipement il faut juste créé
l'équipement qui va vous permettre
d'amener chez vous la télévision et le
téléphone sans rien changer à nos
habitudes si elle voulait toujours
utilisé le même téléphone utilisé la
même télé et on va mais vous mettre ça
chez vous mais ça paraît très simple
en quoi ça m'amènerait c'est génial ça
te paraît très simple un temps après et
où 25 ans à l'époque ça n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas saab est drastiquement les
coûts puisque puisque vous n'en ai plus
qu un tuyau et non pas trois tuyaux pour
amener la même chose va vous diviser par
trois les prix et vous amener quelque
chose de révolutionnaire au foyer ski
mais on avance en france qu'on a été un
peu retardée bulle internet ce qui nous
ramène en force en france
et puisqu'ils permettent de créer cette
notion de boxe et la bonne fête du népal
payne aventure vous l'avez inventé comme
ça vous êtes d'abord essayer de la
chercher d'aller là trouver ailleurs
toujours très naïvement se disent
puisque au début on appelle alcatel et
alcatel ou dix ans les gens de la
nouvelle école mont né dans les années
2000 vous les gens de la nouvelle
économie vous êtes super très bien mais
ça on en reparle dans 15 en quoi ces
révolutionnaires votre truc normalement
15 ans oui les gens pensent que ça ne
peut pas exister maintenant c'est trop
tôt on va d'abord fond de l'internet de
l'adsl cher puis qu'on aura vendu l'adsl
cher peut-être qu'on mettra de la voix
sur l'adsl et puis dans 15 ans mettra la
télé sur un test vous fait dire que ça
peut arriver maintenant alors que les
grands ingénieurs vous dites ça va
mettre des années bas parce que ça nous
voient pas de difficultés technologiques
mais bon alcatel et les constructeurs de
d'équipements télécoms nous disent non
dit on va on va les voir les start up de
la nouvelle économie et vous partez en
californie longue part en californie en
se disant on va trouver ça en californie
et en fait on voit des start-ups sympa
en californie mais qui sont mes dix
kilomètres avant ce qu'on a envie de
faire et on prend les décisions en
californie désire pas puisqu'on trouve
pas cet équipement là on va nous
fabriquer cet équipement électronique en
france on va dessiner on va faire les
logiciels nécessaires pour que ça marche
et que ça fonctionne et donc là ça
devient carton ça marche pas mal
ouais et dix ans après et bien vous
faites un nouveau coup avec ça on vous
presse comme des citrons
on vous presse comme des citrons on
pousse à bout le système je vais vous
dire quelque chose qui est super simple
vous regardez votre facture quand vous
rentrez chez vous
si pour la partie services de votre
abonnement vous payez plus de 19 99
et vous appelez pas votre opérateur et
que vous venez pas où vous ne venez pas
chez free
les pigeons c'est vous et vous le savez
le forfait raquette super arnaque c'est
à dire plus vous êtes pauvre que je vous
en mets dans la tête
- vous avez de moyens plus je vous
vendez sont des choses chères c'est
scandaleux c'est franchement scandaleux
on fait de la marge l'a1 ont fait pas de
pertes au fait de la marge
on fait de la marge à 2 euros à deux on
vous dira que la main voir à quel point
les proposer pour la première fois un
forfait mobile à prix cassés ce qu'aucun
de vos concurrents avaient fait jusqu'à
présent
vous êtes extrêmement agressif même à
l'égard de vos concurrents
l'idée c'est quoi c'est d'aller leur
piquer le maximum de comptes de
consommateurs à tout prix en cassant le
marché qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
que ces trois autres acteurs ont été
condamnés à des amendes record par
l'autorité de la concurrence ils se sont
entendus sur leur préfère bouygues
orange exactement supérieur à 500
millions d'euros
et dresse qu'ils aient de l'entente sur
les prix aux consommateurs
exact et sur des conservations de
niveaux de parts de marché et en fait
nous quand on arrive à ce moment là on
va demander une licence c'est assez
compliqué ce qu'on a beaucoup
d'opposition on a globalement les
autorités de concurrence et de
régulation qui nous soutiennent le
pouvoir politique un petit peu moins
mais on a ra des ministres qui pense que
c'est légitime peut être même un
président qui parfois pense que c'est
légitime d'avoir un quatrième acteur de
téléphonie mobile qui arrivent en force
mais néanmoins on va nous mettre des
barrières parce qu'on dit m
en 2007 on nous dit on va y aller et là
ce que vous venez montrer c'est en 2012
cinq ans après et pendant cinq ans bannu
s'ennuyer nous faire des procès dont on
a encore aujourd'hui des procédures de
nos concurrents sur l'existence de free
mobile a on est on est sept ans après on
a encore aujourd'hui dès que vous
arrivez avec une offre qui est cassé les
prix généralement qu'est-ce qu'on
s'aperçoit on s'aperçoit que dans un
marché oligopolistique les gens allaient
les autres opérateurs abuse sur les prix
là je parle d'un forfait qui s'appelle
le forfait rsa mais en fait ici c'est un
forfait demandés par l'état censé aider
les plus démunis mais en fait ce forfait
rsa il vend plus cher que les autres
forfaits
donc c'est une blague d'un bout à
l'autre à ce moment là c'est une blague
d' à bout à l'autre et on se moque des
consommateurs
d'un bout à l'autre sans raison sans
légitimité et donc on arrive avec une
peur
peur donc avec une agressivité que vous
êtes le chevalier blanc du consommateur
là on essaye on essaye de se dire qu'est
ce qu'on est capable de changer pour
être pour apporter quelque chose de
différent à ce marché et et on a envie
de faire et on est sincère dans notre
envie de changer ce marché et je pense
que c'est ressenti à ce moment là
puisque on recrute un million d'abonnés
le premier jour ce qui en france ça
n'est jamais vu même nom et pourquoi
cette agressivité à l'égard de vos
concurrents
c'est parce que vous parce qu'on a
demandé des comptes parce que je pense
qu'on a souffert jusqu'à la qui nous ont
fait souffrir jusqu'à là que ça a été
dur je pense qu'on a peur c'est
maintenant on y va en disant mais est-ce
que ça va marcher
donc on a investi beaucoup d'argent et
on se dit est ce que ça va marcher de
jeter une forme de revanche quand vous
dites on a souffert jusque là quoi je
pense qu on est on est dans quelque
chose ou on n'est pas bien et comment
ils vous perçoivent les patrons du cac40
à l'époque quand on sort de ça à ça se
fait pas non ce serait pas top
ça ne s'est pas élevé on nous le
reproche c'est à dire on vous retrouve
un peu agressif quand même on this and
an tu sais ce que le truc c'est en face
de nous dans les télécoms ont les trois
autres acteurs y en a un qui est
étatique les deux autres sont des gros
acteurs privés mais avec toujours des
dirigeants ou des contrôles ans qui sont
des gens politiquement extrêmement
existant dans l'environnement donc vous
êtes persuadé pirates comme tous
vraiment le pirate moi mais ça nous va
bien et ça vous va bien
enfin on est assez confortable avec sa
robe alors votre carrière en tant que
pirate vous a permis d'avoir beaucoup de
succès vous avez dynamiter la
concurrence
et puis vous êtes aussi un des rares
patrons avoir fait de la prison
regardez le pdg du groupe de télécoms il
y à t'il contrôle aussi le deuxième
fournisseur d'accès à internet français
free a été mis en examen la nuit
dernière pour proxénétisme aggravé
xavier niel a été écroué il est suspecté
d'avoir investi dans plusieurs
établissements à caractère
pornographique qui aurait même servi de
couverture à des activités de
prostitution
qu'est ce que vous ressentez en voyant
ces images alors mais on est là un
instant
vous remonterez tf1 qui j'ai deux choses
il ya le fond et la forme donc on va
traiter la forme et on traitera le fond
après sur sur la forme
qu'est ce qu'on a on a je suis en guerre
avec tf1 à ce moment là s'ils ont des
sujets de boxe et j'ai la chance de tête
je crois de faire l'ouverture du f à 20
heures ce qui est quand même un
privilège les autres chaînes on parle
pas mais visiblement le tf amateurs
trouve ça très sympa et merci parce que
vous m'avez fait échapper aux reportages
qui était juste derrière à côté la
présentation de claire et très
sympathique a compté ce qui suit
derrière bercy met donc on a on à ce
sujet de à ce sujet de forme
et puis un sujet de fond d'un sentiment
que ce qu'on a pu faire a tellement
dérangé un establishment qu'un certain
nombre de personnes se sont dit on ne
peut pas gagner autant d'argent dans
l'internet on est on est au début des
années 2000 dans dents dans cette
activité qui est internet que personne
ne gagne d'argent dans le monde et
comment ce mec là peut avoir gagné chez
pas un milliard d'euros dans cette
activité la vengeance c'est un début de
vengeance une incompréhension qui
maintient la pression
on a pas mal d'ennemis quoi chercher
chez orange on en eut beaucoup on peut
aller chercher à beaucoup d'endroits
oublié mais qui sait aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est une addition de
personnes maintenant au bout je suis
condamné pour du recel d'abus de bien
social pour deux cent cinquante mille
euros de recel abus dé vous avez été
blanchi pour proxénétisme
oui mais ça fait pas beaucoup de doute
mais encore une fois je me retrouve
devant un juge qui est heureux trouvant
dans une baie qui est tout sauf un juge
rigolo est qui et qui me dit au début en
fait vous faites du blanchi vous avez
blanche et un milliard d'euros non parce
que j'ai une activité qui marche et qui
est là mais au delà de sa renault vendre
bec me dit quelque chose
d'incroyablement plus important pour la
suite de ma vie me dit ce que vous
faites c'est moi j'ai eu tout votre
histoire
ce que vous faites c'est très bien au
moins vous fait bouger les choses
juste la ligne jaune elle est là c'est
pas la peine de la passe et roulé dessus
principale l'autre côté donc les avants
il vous a rendu un service en fait en
vous mettant dans un mois en prison sa
loi et c'est peut-être un syndrome de
stockholm mais j'ai le sentiment qui m'a
rendu
un énorme service en me faisant passer
d'une jeunesse il n'y avait pas beaucoup
de limites d'âge adulte il faut gagner à
l'époque grâce au sexe up
quelques années plus tôt l'équivalent de
quinze mille euros en espèces par moi
oui donc ces cinq millénaires donc c'est
quand même ce que je dis c'est
énormément d'argent mais il ya un côté
proportion qui n'est pas compréhensible
et l'expérience de la prison comment
vous allez traverser cette épreuve
je crois que si on veut faire des choses
dans sa vie faut être positif donc j'ai
comme c'est pas une expérience positive
j'essaye d'en garder un souvenir positif
donc qu'est ce que j'ai fait eh bien
j'ai fait du sport
j'ai perdu 15 kilos j'ai fait durant un
mois j'ai fait du sport
c'était au mois de juin donc il faisait
beau donc je suis sorti je suis sorti
bronzer donc voilà je me dis que c'était
une époque où un moment plutôt positif
et plutôt sympa et et ça va vous changer
pour la suite après on fait une bêtise
sans toi je crois qu on se souvient bien
tu prends donc on arrête la
transgression après on transgresse s'en
passer la ligne jaune
d'accord mais ça n'empêche pas de faire
le lancement de free mobile aux huit ans
après est ce que vous enviez change rien
à l'envi et au et au sujet de réussir et
de s'en sortir
est-ce que vous avez la réponse à la
grande question de la vie de l'univers
et d'autres restent alors c'est yahoo
buzz c'est sympa ne partiront de mercy
en deux c'est une école qu'on a créé
avec une volonté
en fait il ya un truc qui ont 40 2 c'est
le nom de l'école s'était très codé pour
les geeks en réalité en fait c'est pour
tout le monde c'est de dire il ya un
secteur d'activité en foot dans le monde
entier où tout le monde a la garantie de
trouver un job mais il ya une antienne
pénuries énormes de deux jeunes mais
pour la scolarité pour obtenir ces
métiers là ces trois ans d'études à
10000 euros par an pourquoi pas de faire
une école gratuite qui va former des
jeunes d'origines sociales différentes
et leur donner une chance
et en partant de sa et en faisant ça on
crée cette école qui s'appelle caron 2
qui a 4000 élèves à paris puis c'était
comme la marche tellement bien que
maintenant lieu dans 20 pays
n le pirate a disparu non le pirate le
système parce que 42 il a pas de
diplômes au bout pirates le droit
l'entrée c'est quoi c'est un concours en
ligne on n'a pas besoin de savoir lire
et écrire
ok ensuite on vous fait venir dans
l'école ok vous fait bosser bosser
vous fait bosser 450 ans sur un mois les
gens sont dans la rue pour moi c'est
moins de 35 heures non on pirate le
système l'allemagne accord dont vous
êtes robin des bois j'adorerais ça
serait tellement beau et parfait voulait
transformer la société
on la transforme pour ces milliers monde
c'est ainsi qu'ils sont là dans cette
école ouais on les aide
on leur fournit une chance comme on le
fait avec station f dans lequel on va
chercher d'aider des personnes qui ont
envie de créer leur entreprise qui sont
originaires de milieux différents des
réfugiés des jeunes qui sortent de
prison des gens qui viennent de banlieue
difficile
elle est ou la transgression chez
aujourd'hui chez xavier niel on voit que
il ya l'école 42 hockey vous investissez
dans les médias et notamment dans le
monde qui est le journal de référence le
journal de l'establishment qui est à
l'opposé de ce que vous étiez il ya
encore quelques années la transgression
s'est terminée à la transgression c'est
de faire le monde le seul quotidien
rentable de ce pays c'est une
transgression
quand tous les quotidiens ne vivent que
de subventionnement parfois de gens
aisés et tant mieux et tant mieux pour
ces journaux mais c'est d'essayer de
faire de ce journal un journal
économiquement indépendants parce que ça
veut dire qu'il va être indépendant sur
sa partie éditoriale et c'est super
important est de donner les moyens
d'être indépendants pour des siècles et
des siècles ça c'est par rapport au
journal mais vous vous passer dé facto
de l'autre côté du côté de
l'establishment
je vous rappelle que dans le groupe le
monde on a le monde diplomatique j'en
suis pas sûr c'est toujours la même
chose c'est de se dire dans ce système
là est ce qu'on est capable de trouver
des angles différents qui vont permettre
de faire quelque chose de construire
quelque chose et c'était la même idée
qu'on a repris le monde avec pierre
bergé et matthieu pigasse était de se
dire qu'est ce qu'on est capable de
faire que les autres ne font pas pour
que ce journal continue d'exister avec
son âne et pensent qu est ce qu il yad
autres à créer aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres affaires aujourd'hui
énormément de choses à faire et on a
plein de plein de sujets là dessus sur
le souvent des choses non profite avec
la volonté d'aider quand on fait 42
contestation f
on est entouré de jeunes et je pense à
des choses voit des choses que et je
vais reprenant en partie ce que vous
disiez précédemment c'est qu'en
vieillissant on vous embourgeoisez où
les loyers plus élevés nous amène
toujours dessiné
et vous vous êtes dépassés vous êtes
embourgeoisé sur ces 1 c'est un vrai
sujet difficile c'est souvent 10 mai
venez vous avez l'image de
l'entrepreneur parfait entre guillemets
français je suis trop vieux je peux pas
donner envie à mon sens terminé on
arrête
bah ouais je veux pas donner à un môme
de d'envié un monde de 18 ans ou 20 ans
lui disant je suis comme toi je suis pas
crédible
et quel sentiment cela vous procurez
vous c'est de la frustration au
contraire non ça me donne envie d'aider
à créer d'autres modèles décret de credo
trop de modèles de trouver d'autres
jeunes qui vont être capables que de me
donner la possibilité de partir alors
peut-être la retraite tranquille en
disant super il ya un autre groupe de
jeunes qui sont arrivés et qui crée
cette image de jeune entrepreneur ou de
gens qui font bouger d'après vous la
transgression est absolument essentiel
pour pour penser différemment si vous
prenez la nouvelle économie n existe que
dans la transgression
donc si vous voulez être capable
d'attaquer des monopoles quel qu'il soit
il faut que vous soyez transgressif et
c'est toute l'idée du beurre et
transgressif je joue avec la loi et ce
qu'ils ont raison et ce qu'ils ont tort
je ne juge pas ça airbnb la même manière
et pourtant ce sont des entreprises
privées qui modifient notre consommation
qui modifient notre manière de werner
question demain l'avenir pour vous c'est
quoi c'est continuer d'essayer de voir
des bonnes idées pour changer les choses
et de faire bouger les choses de
continuer d'avoir la paix celle envie de
combattre des monopoles quand il y en a
certains endroits ou de financer des
gens pour les combattre il y en a là
auquel vous intéresser tous et non à
chaque fois que vous financez une start
up vous financer un fonds financé des
gens pour aller combattre un monopole on
finance de start up par semaine elles
sont toutes dans cette activité là
chaque semaine on va aller fabriquer
chez pas du diamant synthétique on va
s'amuser à combattre compte un certain
nombre de choses on va financer ou à
financer ou à financer des sujets
agricoles on va les financer des choses
avec la volonté d'essayer de se dire il
y à il ya des forces il ya des
oligopoles il y à des lobbys allons
jouer contre eux merci infiniment merci
à vous
[Musique]